three-time national champ urban meyer on
loan from fox sports their college
football analyst coach how are you this
morning
i'm good dan good to see you how do you
watch football now
as an analyst as opposed to a you know
coach
oh it's about the same i you know i just
really enjoy
the intricacies of the game you know
it's hard for me to just watch it and
and i i do i pull for i don't really
pull for teams i pull for my former
players in the nfl and and
pull for guys i recruit and i know so
it's more personal with me but
you know i love to look at you know what
is going on in the locker room what's
going on in that huddle what are they
thinking during this
play as opposed to hey nice catch you
know so
i i love looking at the intricacies of
the game
you know that when you had joe burrow
did you understand how good
like this joe burrow now as opposed to
what you saw
back then like what's the biggest
difference with joe burrow
oh that's a great story joe burrow was
under recruited really not recruited you
know we
he had very few offers uh our offense
coordinator i want watched him play and
called me i remember zoomed with me or
not zoom whatever that facetime
and said you have to watch him throw
here's your next alex smith is exactly
what was said and i was like
i had a little you know angst about it
because he wasn't highly recruited but
then you started watching and then
the thing you meet him and his family
his father was a long time coach his
mom's incredible
and this kid was a state champion
basketball player competitor
so he started very slow his release his
release time was very slow his arm
strength was average
but he was an absolute grinder and by
the time
you know it came down he was our backup
quarterback and broke his hand and
that's when dwayne haskins took
advantage of the opportunity but we saw
this coming to say i saw him being the
number one pick overall
i'm not sure many people saw that but
when you assess that
that position still the hardest to
assess because if you look at
look at the quarterbacks in the nfl and
people had doubts about
patrick mahomes or kyler murray was too
short russell wilson was too short
how do you what do you look for what's
the one thing or two things that you go
that's what i wanted my quarterback and
you know then i'll i'll recruit him
we've been fortunate we've had all good
quarterbacks and and we've made very few
mistakes at that position and because i
i actually learned remember jeff tetford
he was the coach at
cal in oregon and at one point i still
think one of the greatest quarterback
coaches of all time and i was a young
head coach and i
i asked that same question what do you
why do you keep having it's not by
chance that you have these great
quarterbacks it's what do you look for
and that's when i came up our criteria
really through coach tedford was
number one is competitor number two is
toughness leadership
intelligence adaptability and we would
not take a guy
that didn't have those qualities notice
i didn't say arm strength and release
point because
you can teach that you can't teach those
other equalities
who's the guy you didn't get quarterback
yeah
deshaun watson i worked so he was
committed so early
and uh i remember flying there and i
thought we had him thinking about it but
clemson did such a great job recruiting
him that
i still think he's one of the greatest
competitors quarterback still is
but deshawn watson was the one but you
know what amazed me though coach is he
did everything you wanted a quarterback
to do in college
but then people still had doubts about
him going into the nfl
that's what i don't understand well nfl
it amazes me when i hear people say well
i'm not sure he'll make it because nfl
is a quarterback
game and i'm thinking well wait a minute
so was college a quarterback game
so it's high school football and peewee
it's a quarterback sport
and quarterbacks in the nfl i i hear
people blame them
when they're stuck on a really lousy
team you know i remember dwayne haskins
last year
i mean that is a found not throwing
stones here but
the redskins were bad last year they
fired their coach there were some
cultural issues within the organization
and the team
and it was dwayne i remember i was doing
interviews people are saying well dwayne
haskins
you know is he going to make it and i'm
thinking wait a minute put him on a
really good team and he'll make it
so i it's still a team sport and the
great quarterbacks they're competitors
but they also
they're surrounded by really good people
but also what happens is sometimes you
benefit by going in the
late uh or you know mid first round or
late person you're going to a better
team you might have to wait a little
longer but patrick mahomes went to a
kansas city team that was loaded
uh you know aaron rodgers when he went
late you know you got into a good
system there where as if you know joe's
going joe burrow's going to a bad
bengals team
might take him a lot longer than it will
you know dwayne haskins uh
you know well the redskins aren't much
better than than the bengals there but
you know what i mean deshawn watson
going to the texans they had an
established team there as well so it
feels like
less pressure and you go to a better
team well think
i think alex smith is a poster child for
that he was a
number one pick overall went to a really
bad team
and the the narrative on alex smith was
he was a bust
in the first pick overall and i i
remember saying i did interviews too and
if alex smith
can't play an nfl i will never coach a
quarterback to complain nfl because
you know never mind the fact that the
niners were bad on defense battle and
special teams are bad on offense but now
it's alex smith's fault
so you're right and i i worry about joe
but i
from what joe tells me because i talked
to joe there's a lot of positive right
now with the bengals in that
organization and
joe joe's joe's in a positive you know
they got to win some games
but he's very positive about the future
right now he's urban meyer fox sports
college football analyst
uh big noon kickoff pre-game show it
starts every saturday morning at 10 a.m
eastern
pac-12 i don't know if they've
officially announced when they're coming
back i was told it's the week after
halloween
we know the big ten's coming back how
long would it take you to get your team
ready
do you think well i talked to a couple
coaches at usc recently and they're not
even out there having seven on seven
they're not practicing because of the
uh the state mandates uh the one thing
that ohio state in the big ten those
players
everywhere everybody was practicing you
know they weren't hitting they weren't
in contact but at least they're out
functioning
in in seven on seven and drill work and
so
they're there's come back to return will
be much quicker the pac-12 right now
i'm not talking about utah but the i
believe oregon i believe california they
can't even have
i was told yesterday this is amazing to
me you can't have more than 12 people
out there working out and i'm thinking
why you know what's the problem here and
so
once again i don't want to get into all
the because the pandemic obviously is
awful but it's going to take some time
unless they release those
standards that people can go out and
start probably if you can't do that yeah
i don't know how they're gonna be ready
yeah that's what i you know what i was
told is they're gonna try to play
a six-game regular season schedule and
then that
seventh week it'll be first place versus
first place second place versus second
same thing the big ten is doing i i just
don't know if the pac-12 gets off the
ground here coach
well right now if they don't the
recruiting disadvantage that pac-12 will
face
for a long period of time dan will be
catastrophic is such a hard word to use
when you're talking about sports but
catastrophic i mean the pac-12 right now
has already had recent struggles in
years
think about the day when pete carroll
matliner and my teammates reggie bush
and matt liner were playing
you didn't even think about recruiting
la because you're not going to beat
you're not going to beat usc ucla you're
not now
you can go out there and you can compete
against those that
that conference because they're down
they have to get going
how would you use that though if you
were recruiting and you were going after
a kid in pac pac-12 territory if they
didn't play this year
how would you use that i've noticed in
the last five years dan it's been easier
to go get
we never recruited california you know
wyatt davis uh
he's going to be a first round draft
pick offensive guard you you want you
want first of all you won't travel that
far because you have enough good players
but
when you see a top five guy in a
position and you can
go in there and you can see that they're
competing in stadiums that aren't full
that nighttime is the only time you can
see them on national television there's
so many obstacles and
you know you want to come to a place
that sells out every game and you want
to be on national tv every week and
a chance to be a high draft pick you
know a lot of times it sells itself
did you ever feel sorry when you faced
michigan and you were
running up the score roughing them up a
little bit
oh this is going to create a lot of
headline but no
well no if you said that you felt sorry
for him that would have created a
headline i think coaching
because i i was there a couple years ago
when
you know ohio state when haskins was
quarterbacking
and it wasn't stopping i think that
probably could have put up
70 75 if you wanted to but do you
run up the score on michigan if you can
i think your job is the players
how can i answer this politically
correct
our players work that game every year
you get a chance to go into play i'm not
going to tell them to slow down
okay yeah there's nothing wrong with
that how do we come up with a final four
here in college football this will be i
think the committee
we mentioned this on big new kickoff
that this is unprecedented you might
have
how about the sec playing ten conference
games you know i coached in that
conference for six years and
even the the so-called bottom half of
that conference is
outstanding there's probably eight teams
in that league that think they can win a
national title so
this the inequity of scheduling right
now is i i've never witnessed anything
like this you're looking at
clemson will be a two to three touchdown
favorite in every game other than notre
dame
ohio state will be a two to three
touchdown favorite
in every game maybe but one and then you
look at alabama
lsu's got four teams in the six week
period in the top eleven i think top 11
top 13
and clemson won't play one so the
inequity i hope everybody looks
deeply at the conference and the
scheduling the strength of schedule
because i've always been a
believer they have to have a little more
leeway because i think the scc will lose
two games the top teams will lose two
games
i was told nebraska got taken to the
woodshed because
the governor the athletic director the
coach they were going to go rogue here
and all of a sudden they say oh you want
to play football all right come to
columbus you got ohio state to start and
we're going to send wisconsin out there
do you think the big 10 sent a message
to
uh nebraska to you know let's keep it
all in house here
no no there if they did first of all no
way
no way could you do that you know i
remember when scott frost first got
there one of our coaches meetings he
brought up that they've had the hardest
schedule in the big ten for years and
years and years and
no one really knew that but he broke
down but because nebraska
is a prime time name and so was the
wolverines
ohio state and penn state and people
want to see those games so
they seem to play you never saw nebraska
play rutgers or maryland
you saw them play the big dogs all the
time in the east you know the
like i said the buckeyes and the penn
state and the wolverines um
so i don't know why they keep getting
the most i can't i can't believe that
someone would really do that
yeah but they had to be upset
kevin warren had to be upset with what
nebraska was saying though coach yeah
but
for people that make comments that how
can nebraska say that they've never
coached
i i would argue they never coached the
job of a coach a.d and a president fight
for their players if they felt that was
wrong
i commend them i commend scott frost for
and the a.d
and the president for swinging as hard
as they can i commend the athletes at
ohio state and other penn state
and and the wolverine i mean everybody
fought they thought that was wrong and
they fought they did it
they did it respectfully what they
thought good to visit with you coach
hope you're doing well
having fun and uh you know enjoying
football differently now
i am i really thank god i enjoy that fox
crew because we we have a lot of time to
stay engaged stay relevant and
involved in this great game so thank you
dan thank you coach that's urban meyer
fox sports college football analyst
three-time national champ
and of course was it florida utah and
ohio state